just not give up anything to youngers as
leo has said time and time again break
water all the way from Port Alberni you
have a lot of help from his team
somebody who's taking care of his team
right now is demar derozan knock it down
a three - roses getting out aggressively
whose kind of playing a soft man-to-man
DeRozan is good at the rim that's an
excellent point you master that the game
becomes so much easier
DeRozan quick move on Brogdon spinning
around the man's ready deploy in this
game here look at the defense by Brogdon
tamargo Rosen says you gotta do better
than that like a great position on -
they're gonna review though just have
five rebounds and three assists here is
what was called - Chu prosper and have
to review more than likely they'll make
that of three years of age
DeRozan another three
DeMar DeRozan from the soon as it batted
away the lawn gets it back to DeMar
DeMar
[Applause]
sweet is that you're in the first
quarter tomorrow
traffic jam he just opens up before
for neon some time with la familia 5655
[Music]
got 20 priests Givens passing lane
there's everybody else two rows in the
track of the 11 players that have played
all of them has scored two runs and from
deep as he drills it from Cookstown
first meeting between the Bucks and the
Raptors Bucks in the first round chested
Toronto the Rosen's got 37 in Arma and
check out the Rose listen jumper here
stop on a dime straight up beautiful art
rotation on the ball with the lengthy
West Coast trip early on in the season
DeMarre over yonder she's got 39 spend
the man right here this is a slide shot
against the tennis composters have won
13 of 15 against Milwaukee
to applaud
[Applause]
watch Ibaka here he gets beat on a
baseline but then recovers and makes the
block and then DeMar DeRozan strong move
in a pain 21 points here's DeRozan
drives all sorts of contact don't
now just great body control and strength
defensive plays and that's why he could
stay in
giant step before
Raptors pi/4